عرضت حماس ردها على
اتفاق الرهائن ووقف إطلاق النار المقترح والذي
يدعو إلى انسحاب إسرائيلي تدريجي
من غزة خلال
هدنة مدتها أربعة أشهر ونصف والتي ستشهد أيضًا
إطلاق سراح الرهائن الإسرائيليين
مقابل أسرى فلسطينيين
وجهود إنسانية ضخمة.  لكن في
مؤتمر صحفي الليلة قال رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو إن ذلك
لن يحدث وإن الهجوم المضاد
سيستمر بوتيرة
نحن في طريقنا لإكمال النصر،
النصر يمكن تحقيقه، إنها ليست
مسألة سنوات أو عقود، إنها مسألة
أشهر حوالي 1200 عام.  قُتل شخص
في 7 أكتوبر/تشرين الأول داخل إسرائيل،
وقُتل أكثر من 27 ألف شخص في غزة
منذ ذلك الحين وفقًا للسلطات الصحية الخاصة بهم. وفي
وقت سابق،
قال وزير الخارجية الأمريكي أنتوني بلينكين إن
اقتراح حماس يتم دراسته بشكل مكثف
من قبل كل من الولايات المتحدة وإسرائيل، وأنه
كان  لقاء مع رئيس الوزراء
وأيضا مع رئيس السلطة الفلسطينية
محمود عباس في رالا، الآن
ضيفي الأول الليلة كان مديرا
لتخطيط السياسات في
وزارة الخارجية ولمدة عقدين من الزمن
مديرا لمجلس
العلاقات الخارجية، وقد انضم إليّ ريتشارد من
نيودلهي.  يورك مرحبًا بك مرة أخرى في
البرنامج، من الجيد أن أكون معك يا كريستيان،
لست متأكدًا من الترتيب الذي يجب أن أبدأ به ولكن هل
يجب أن نبدأ مع رئيس
الوزراء أه وهو آخر الأخبار
بشكل أساسي الذي يلغي كل
ما تم الإبلاغ عنه طوال اليوم بهذا
أه  الافراج عن ما يسمى كما تعلمون
اقتراح حماس ما رأيك في
قوله لا وأنهم سيستمرون في
استكمال
النصر بشكل جيد أنا لست مندهشا ولكن ما
أعادني قليلا إلى الوراء هو
تعليقه الذي  النصر الكامل أن
إبادة حماس والقضاء عليها يلوح
في الأفق أه أجد أنه من الصعب أن
أتخيل ذلك لأنني لست متأكدا من أنه
هدف قابل للتحقيق نظرا لطبيعة
حماس المسيحية لذلك أنا فقط لا
أفهم المنطق الذي يطول أكثر من
أيام  أو أسابيع أو أشهر من
النشاط العسكري الإسرائيلي سوف يحل
المشكلة بالنسبة لهم، ولا يزال من الواضح أنه لا
يتضمن أي شيء عما
سيأتي بعد ذلك فيما يتعلق
بالحكم، لذلك لا أعتقد أن الكثير من
الناس في إسرائيل سيفعلون ذلك.
اقتنع بذلك ومن الواضح أنه
سيتعرض لضغوط حتى
لا يرفض على الأقل ما
تعرضه حماس بشكل قاطع لأنه يفتح
إمكانية استعادة
الرهائن المتبقين، لذا سمعت ما قاله رئيس الوزراء
ولكن يبدو أنه  أنا لست
موقفا غير مستدام لأقول ببساطة
أننا سنواصل القيام بما نقوم به
ولسنا مهتمين بأي
شيء يتم مناقشته فقط في
قضية واحدة أه الجنرال المسؤول عن
جزء من العملية في غزة
خاصة  في الجنوب سوف يفشل
في الانجراف، فهو لن يجيب عندما
سئل هل يعرفون ما إذا كان يحيى
سينا، زعيم حماس الأعلى الذي يسعون إليه
جميعًا، هل لا يزال هناك، هل
قبضوا عليه، هل يقتربون منه و و
يبدو أن المراسلين يقولون إنك
تعلم أنه ترك الباب مفتوحًا أمام إمكانية
هروب سينوا عبر
الحدود إلى مصر أو أو إلى
أي مكان آخر، ما مدى أهمية
ذلك في ضوء ما
قاله رئيس الوزراء الليلة أننا سنذهب
إلى  مواصلة
النصر الشامل حسنًا، إنه أمر مهم لأن
إحدى الطرق التي يمكن للإسرائيليين من خلالها
القول بأن الكثير مما فعلوه
كان مبررًا من خلال الاستيلاء على قيادة حماس
العسكرية أه لكنك لا
تحتاج إلى عمليات عسكرية واسعة النطاق للقيام
بذلك.  قد أعتقد أن شيئًا أكثر
سرية أو قياسًا أو استهدافًا هو ما
قد يدور في ذهنك، وهو بالمناسبة أيضًا
أحد الأسباب التي تجعلني أواجه صعوبة في
تخيل أي حكومة إسرائيلية أه
توافق على
إطلاق نار مطلق على SE إذا وافقوا في اليوم التالي  لقد
حصلوا بطريقة ما على معلومات استخباراتية مفادها أنه
يمكنهم الحصول على هذا أو ذاك
زعيم الهماش، من الصعب بالنسبة لي أن أتخيل على
الأقل أنني لا أعرف عنك ولكن من
الصعب بالنسبة لي أن أتخيل أنهم ليسوا هم لا
يتصرفون بناءً على ذلك، لذلك تمكنت مرة أخرى من رؤية
الإسرائيليون يوقعون على نوع ما من
وقف العمليات العسكرية الكبرى،
أجد من الصعب أن أتخيلهم يوقعون على
وقف إطلاق نار مطلق غير مشروط ومفتوح المدة، وذلك نظرًا لحقيقة أن
رئيس الوزراء قام بالفعل بالتمييز
بين ما يمكن أن يفعله وما لا يفعله
بخلاف المضي قدمًا بكامل قوته فيما يتعلق
بالجيش، أين يترك ذلك وزير
الخارجية يومض والذي لا يزال هناك
يحاول إجراء مفاوضات أه لقد قام
بالتنقل بين الحلفاء الآخرين كما تعلمون
في منطقة الخليج الآن
في تل أبيب وفي رومالا حيث
هل هذا يترك
الجهد الأمريكي جيدًا بشكل أساسي الآن لديك
فكرتان هناك، لديك فكرة
الولايات المتحدة مع الحضيض
وممثلي مصر وإسرائيل كانوا يتفاوضون على
اقتراح أكثر تواضعًا لمدة 45 يومًا أو نحو ذلك أه وقف إطلاق النار في الأساس
وقفة أخرى مع مختلف
تبادل الرهائن والأسرى أه ثم لديك
فكرة حماس وهي أطول بكثير ولكنها
تدعو أيضًا إلى الانسحاب الإسرائيلي أه وهو
شيء كبير كبير وفي
الأساس نهاية للصراع
وأنا تقريبًا ما تملكه حماس  إن
طرح كريستيان على الطاولة هو
عودة إلى ما كان موجودًا قبل أكتوبر،
وأعتقد أن هذا
جسر بعيد جدًا بالنسبة للإسرائيليين، لذلك أعتقد أن
ما يجب أن يفعله توني بلينكين هو
العمل على شيء لا يستبعد
ما تطرحه حماس هناك أو
شيء طموح ولكن خطوة
بخطوة لذلك أعتقد أن فكرة الاستمرار في
الضغط من أجل أه وقفة محدودة سواء
كانت شهرًا وستة أسابيع
وشهرين، ماذا لديك مع المساعدات التي تذهب للرهائن
وإخراج بعض السجناء
أعتقد أن التبادل هو أذكى طريقة
ولا يستبعد شيئًا أكثر
طموحًا في المستقبل